اذا مشاهدينا اتساع الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ودخولها عامها الثاني دفع بعض
الدول لتغيير وجهه نظرها بشان ارسال
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا
مثلا قالت ان سويسرا قد تصبح حجره عثره
امام المساعدات المقدمه لاوكرانيا وهو ما
سيؤدي الى حاله من الاحباط في المعسكر
الغربي الداعم الصحيفه ايضا اضافت ان
الجهود الغربيه اصطدمت بحاجز يعتبر
تقليديا في سويسرا منذ قرون وهو الحياد
فالدوله الواقعه وسط القاره العجوز موطن
لصناعه اسلحه متطوره لكنها في ذات الوقت
تلتزم بمبدا الابتعاد عن الحروب الخارجيه
على الارض يعني هذا ان تقوم سويسرا بحظر
تصدير واعاده تصدير الاسلحه والذخيرا الى
مناطق النزاع كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا الموقف
السويس هو عائق امام الناتو مثلا على سبيل
المثال الذي تسعى لانداد اوكرانيا بشكل
متواصل بمختلف انواع الاسلحه والذخيره
ويدخل حياد سويسرا الجهود الغربيه في عنق
زجاجه مع الانقطاعات في سلسله توريد
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا التي تستهلكها
بوتيره اسرع بكثير ما يمكن لشركائها
الغربيين انتاجه بالاضافه لهذه الضغوط
الغربيه على يخطط مشرعون اوكرانيون من
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان لارسال
وفد خاص لزياره العاصمه السويسريه
للمطالبه بتغيير السياسات اعاقه جهود
التصدير اشتكت منها دول كاسبانيا
والدنمارك بعد رفض سويسرا السماح بتصدير
انظمه الدفاع الجوي سبايدر وبيرانا ثلاثه
الى اوكرانيا وكلاهما يحتوي على اجزاء
سويسريه الصنع ايضا برلين كانت ضغطت مرارا
على
تغيير سياستها بعدما رفضت الاخيره طلبات
الاذن بارسال ذخيره مصنوعه في سويسرا سبق
لالمانيا ان اشترتها ويشمل هذا منظومه
التي نشرتها اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الانتقادات الموجهه لسويسرا مشاهدينا جاءت
كذلك من امين عام الناتو يانس الشهر
الماضي عندما تحدث عن سويسرا مواربه وقال
انه في حاله اوكرانيا لا يتعلق الامر
بالحياد بل هو مرتبط باحترام الحق في
الدفاع عن النفس وحمايه سياده القانون
والدفاع ايضا عن ميثاق الامم المتحده
بينما قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ان الامتناع عن التصويت ليس خيارا لسويسرا
وان على كل الدول ان تختار جانبا تنضم له
جانب القانون او قانون القوه وجانب
الديمقراطيه او الاستبداد على حد قول
فوندرلين نشير هنا سريعه مشاهدينا الى ان
سويسرا تتخذ موقفا يعرف باسم الحياد
المسلح الذي تنظمه المعاهدات الدوليه
والتشريعات المحليه ما يعني ان البلاد
تحتفظ بقوه كبيره لحمايه سيادتها لكنها
تبقى بعيده عن النزاعات الخارجيه لهذا
السويسرا بانه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك تنازل
عن الحياد لانه جزء من نظامها الدستوري
خلال الاسابيع الاولى من حرب اوكرانيا نجح
القاده الاوروبيون والمتظاهرون المحليون
في الضغط على السويسرا للانضمام الى
عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد موسكو وهو ما
دعى روسيا الى اضافه سويسرا الى قائمه
الدول غير الصديقه اما في ملف التسليح
اثارت الضغوط من دول مثل المانيا وهي اكبر
مشتري للاسلحه السويسريه والتي هددت
بالغاء عقود طويله الاجل مع شركه سويسريه
نقاشا في البرلمان السويسري حول تعديل
قوانينها للسماح لدول ثالثه محدده باعاده
تصدير الاسلحه والذخيره وفي وقت صاغ فيه
مشرعون السويسريون مجموعه من التعديلات
على القانون المنظم لتجاره الاسلحه الا
انه ليس من الواضح ما اذا كان بالامكان
حشده الاغلبيه في البرلمان حتى وان تم
الاقتراح قريبا فهو لن يدخل حيز التنفيذ
الا في وقت مبكر من العام المقبل هذا في
اروقه وكواليس السياسه السويسريه اما في
الشارع فقد افاد استطلاع للرائي نشر امس
سويسرا من كل اثنين يؤيد ان تقوم الدول
التي اشترت اسلحه سويسريه باعاده
التصديرها الى اوكرانيا
نصف الشعب مؤيد للفكره مع معارضه
46% من السويسريه
[موسيقى]